let's just pick up on those results from
the local elections if we can i mean
we've got a historically unpopular prime
minister the labour party should have
done better shouldn't they
we've made huge strides especially when
you compare where we were at the last
general election where the labour party
had a near-death experience and you
mentioned the results in london of
course there were remarkable results in
places like westminster i'm sat in labor
run westminster who'd have thought it
but i'd argue even as a as an mp on the
london essex border that what happens in
london is less significant
than some of the
amazing results we saw in those places
that we need to win back cumberland the
new cumbria council that includes
constituencies like copeland workington
carlisle the red wall seats that labour
needs to win back they went to labor you
think about the original red wall that
fell in scotland labour now in second
place giving the smp a run for their
money in places like glasgow so look
we're not complacent about this and i
don't want anyone who either cast their
vote for labour or is yet to be
persuaded to vote labor that we're cocky
or complacent we know there's more work
to do to win the next general election
but compared to where we were compared
with the
breach of trust that occurred between
labor and our traditional supporters as
well as those who tend to float as
voters from one election to the other i
think we've got a remarkable result here
huge strides forward and labour is in a
position to build on that head of the
next general election to be in a
position to win the next general
election i mean everyone would say that
strides have been taken but on the
general election you'll know that the
extrapolation says that it would be a
hung parliament with this kind of result
and the red wool come on wes it hasn't
been rebuilt has it
i i don't doubt there's more to do but
you know cumbria hartley paul where we
had
good results that would have delivered a
labour mp sunderland where the tories
really went after us hoping to bring
down that labour council
didn't happen and of course it's not
just the red wall where we've made
advances if you look further down south
places like worthing where i think five
years ago or so we didn't have any labor
councils councillors is now a labor
council if you look at southampton where
there's you know two constituencies
there one of which we need to win back
advances there so as i say we're not
complacent about it we're not cocky
about it but compared to where we were
at the last general election really
important strides and i mean you know
the other result i would point out as
well which you know
i think really stands out in terms of
the progress we've made is barnet
significant jewish population i went
across to campaign there a couple of
times myself and i was struck by the
fact that compared to where labour was
on the issue of anti-semitism for
example
i was to be honest i felt a huge sigh of
relief the jewish voters felt able to
return to labour many of whom lifelong
labour voters felt let down previously
have seen the advances seen the changes
that have been made under kirsten's
leadership and feel they can call labour
their home again so these are important
strides forward you mentioned what would
this mean if there were a general
election you're right hung parliament
labour is the largest party well that is
remarkable progress in two years or so
of kirsten being leader of the labour
party of course there's more to do i
don't want to sound the least bit
complacent about that but i think that's
what they that the next period
of kiers leadership and opposition is
about it's about building on the
progress that's made and turning the
hostility to the conservatives in
government a desire to see the
conservatives out of government which is
what i think these results show into a
hunger and appetite for a labor
government there's more work to do no
doubt about that but we've got firm
foundations from which labour can win
the next general election whereas we
know that you're not complacent is that
work going to involve some kind of
alliance you know that you're way off in
scotland have you thought about a
political alliance with the smp
no no we're we're in completely
different places to the smp on the
fundamental issue of the future of the
united kingdom no deals no patch no
compromise on that uh and and we're in
it to win it we want to win the next
general election outright i think these
results do provide us the foundation in
which to do that but you know we're not
we're not interested in back room deals
or stitch ups and when it comes to the
smp specifically we are very very clear
about where we stand on the future of
the united kingdom the future of the
union and now following these results in
scotland it's very clear that it's labor
giving the snp a run for their money the
conservatives in scotland have fallen
far back not least because they've been
trashed by their own leadership in
westminster and have a weak and
spineless leader in scotland and i think
actually it's the labour party now that
provides the way forward for the future
of the united kingdom
where people can actually vote not just
to oppose the tories in scotland through
the snp they can vote to replace the
tories in scotland by voting labour at
the next general election
okay where's that
on the local elections thank you very
much that now i've got to ask you about
the situation facing secure stammer and
before i ask you the question i'm not
comparing the two situations make that
very clear but if secure stammer
is fined
for having broken lockdown rules should
he resign
i really don't think it's going to come
to that because the police have looked
at this before i don't see any reason
why
now they would draw any other conclusion
to the one they drew when they were last
asked to look at this where they looked
at it on the basis of the complaint said
no case to answer no action to be taken
that's what i expect happen this time of
course we'll fully cooperate with the
police give them all of the information
they need to make their conclusions it's
right the police are looking at this
and i think they'll come to the same
conclusion they did last time now as you
know there's always a tweet for these
situations shakir had tweeted that after
months of denials the pm is under
criminal investigation he needs to do
the decent thing and resign i mean he's
under investigation now isn't he
but it wasn't the fact that the prime
minister was simply under investigation
we'd had months and months and months
of the prime minister denying there were
any events in number 10 that was proven
to be false the prime minister was
proven to have lied to the house of
commons and that in and of itself is a
resignation offence
under the ministerial code and it's one
of the many many reasons why boris
johnson should have already resigned
in this case we have been clear and care
has been clear all the way through
that no rules were broken this was a you
know desperate attempt by the
conservatives to muddy together events
that were a year apart in very different
circumstances we will provide the police
with all of the information we need but
we are really confident that they will
reach the same conclusion they did last
time because kirstama is someone who is
honest who practices what he preaches
and i think in this case
once the police have done their work
care will be vindicated we'll move on
and actually pressure will mount on
boris johnson i mean why on earth that
man is still in number 10 i don't know
but maybe the fact that conservatives
have suffered a humiliating defeat at
this election might concentrate the
minds of conservative mps to grow a
spine and give the country better
leadership that we deserve